vous êtes originaire du nord de la
France
la métropole lilloise mais j'habitais à
Paris pendant longtemps
vous avez une suivi une formation en
école de commerce
que vous avez travaillé dans la
publicité la communication absolument
c'est ça oui
je passe bien vous travaillez encore et
je suis artiste également
photos sculpture musique d'accord très
bien
donc dire artiste peintre chez vous vous
avez un atelier chez moi c'est mon
atelier d'accord très bien c'est ça oui
en 2008 vous donnez des sens à votre
fils aux Philippines
un très bon souvenir je souhaitais
accoucher dans l'eau
la température du lieu s'y prétend
volontiers et
dans un climat favorable ce que vous
avez dit oui
en tout point de vue que ce soit en
termes de météo pour accoucher dans
l'eau
très peu de temps
vous rentrez à Paris après votre
accouchement où vous avez donc un petit
appartement que vous m'avez dit que vous
habitez Paris maintenant vous l'avez
déclaré seul en rentrant en France
vous étiez séparé du papa c'est ça vous
êtes séparés du papa j'ai été seul à le
déclarer effectivement c'est ça le papa
il vous a quitté depuis longtemps
d'accord très bien non mais c'est
important qu'on est toutes les données
voilà pour comprendre cette histoire
donc vous vivez seul avec votre fils
oui
si on peut dire au début on est tout le
temps à l'extérieur et avec moultany
il grandit donc avant de vous votre fils
on a pu lire dans la presse que
l'appartement dans lequel vous voyez
vous vivez dans un petit appartement à
Paris
oui l'équivalent d'un AF2 d'accord on a
pu lire dans la presse que l'appartement
était insalubre est-ce que vous
confirmez non pas du tout pas du tout
pour vous
il y a l'électricité des fenêtres enfin
pareil fou de le dire mais tout
fonctionne instrument de chauffage je
lis les
définitions de la salubrité
effectivement c'était des conditions
insaluques quasiment sans lumière un
enfant cloître dans sa chambre
malnutri seul et sans éducation scolaire
donc tout un ensemble qui font que les
services sociaux se sont émus donc voilà
on a décrit des conditions terribles
pour cet enfant madame mais qui ne
correspond pas à la réalité
c'est tellement incroyable tout ce qu'on
raconte c'est vraiment tellement
diamétralement à l'opposé de notre vécu
on était tout le temps à l'extérieur je
ne sais pas qui qui a inventé ça alors
je pense que enfin c'est un journaliste
en fait j'ai rencontré un peu la
personne en fait qui qui a écrit ça qui
s'est excusé et qui a fait d'autres
articles depuis qui est venu à la maison
qui qui a vu le jardin le salon la
bibliothèque etc alors d'en parler dans
un instant de ça parce que les
téléspectateurs comprennent bien cette
affaire donc votre fils lorsque votre
fils a un an et demi vous vous
renseignez pour le scolariser oui
absolument d'accord faites même des
démarches mais au final vous rendez
compte que l'école n'est pas obligatoire
en France c'est ça et que c'est
l'instruction qui est obligatoire vous
décidez donc de ne pas le mettre à
l'école
oui oui c'est c'est à peu près ça
j'avais fait la démarche vous dites
c'est moi qui vais lui donner les
instructions dans un premier temps en
étant maman je pensais vraiment à
travailler l'autonomie de mon enfant et
je pensais que l'école était la voix
royale pour ça donc je me suis renseigné
effectivement comme vous le disiez très
tôt pour c'est ce scolarisation donc il
apprend les bases de lecture de
mathématiques de sciences avec vous oui
absolument c'est vous qui lui donnez des
cours
il a l'équivalent de de quelle classe
aujourd'hui il a 14 ans
bien il a des acquis qui sont parfois
supérieurs à un enfant qui qui va à
l'école qui a une moyenne à l'école et
il a il y a certaines matières
ou n'ayant pas été à proprement parler
sur un une éducation scolaire à
proprement parler
où il a moins de connaissances mais
voilà il a d'autres domaines de
compétences vous dites qu'il va aller
souvent dans des bibliothèques dans des
musiques qui jouaient des instruments
pour la lecture où choisissez la méthode
Montessori pour qu'il apprenne les
sciences vous l'emmenez souvent à la
Cité des Sciences donc c'était pas une
éducation voilà comme comme tout le
monde voilà
vous dites il sortait dans la rue il
avait des amis votre fils ou pas il a
des amis il a des amis oui évidemment
tous les jours
parce que comme il était pas à l'école
il avait des potes de son âge oui oui
bien sûr depuis tout petit papa on était
tous les
potes c'est des enfants d'amis c'est
quoi les enfants d'amis et puis quand il
était tout petit aussi on allait tous
les jours
passif que je refasse l'historique
au parc puis après au fur et à mesure
dans des ateliers des tournois de cartes
des activités diverses et variées où il
rencontrait ses peurs alors disons plus
tard en 2018 donc vous avez besoin de
plus d'espace vous vous tentez
d'acquérir un bien en Bretagne c'est ça
donc c'était pour déménager avec votre
fils définitivement
en faisant la navette nous pensions
il a 10 ans là il a 10 ans que vous
allez la réuni il est toujours pas
scolarisé oui
le confinement arrive grosso modo voilà
est-ce que c'est un enfant comme les
autres skis il a un téléphone oui il
allait sur les réseaux sociaux tout ça
ah oui oui sur internet
il a déjà fait une soirée avec des amis
par exemple tout ça
le premier juillet dernier votre fils
est victime d'un choc
anaphylactique c'est une très grosse
allergie et là vous l'amener aux
urgences
forcément vous êtes en panique vous
l'emmenez voir des médecins pour faire
des contrôles de temps en temps où
c'était la première fois qu'il allait
voir un médecin non non il avait un
pédiatre quand il était petit et après
qui a pris la retraite
mais bon
votre fils se rétablit aux urgences et
vous décidez de rentrer à la maison
vous en avez ras le bol d'attendre donc
en fait pour rester aux urgences vous
voyez que c'est très long vous partez
c'est ça
donc nous allons aux urgences son
allergie se résorbe d'elle-même
si c'est en forme il me dit que que
lui-même est en forme il demande à
rentrer à la maison
je connais un petit peu le sujet des
allergies et des personnes qui décident
de tension de l'hôpital d'informer
l'accueil de votre départ vous sortez
tranquillement mais là il y a un médecin
qui vous rattrape
oui c'est ça qui a l'air très nerveux
derrière nous et vous dit quoi qui
était déjà dans on avait qu'une forme de
pression
avant ça beaucoup de questionnaires
administratifs pas le rapport avec la
santé au tenté de mon enfant et son
bien-être
[Musique]
je pêche un peu peut-être sur les
chiffres voilà elle est suivie
administrative
harmonieux parce que 25 kg vous rendez
compte 25 kilos à 14 ans c'est deux fois
moins que le poids moyen un enfant de
son âge
ne pas manger et ça c'est
hallucinant d'entendre ça
il a toujours eu à manger enfin c'est ça
me paraît fou de devoir le dire quoi
mais évidemment qu'il a toujours eu à
manger à sa fin dites vous le nourrissez
de fromage et de viande de Grisons
14 ans 25 kg
en fait
vous trouvez pas qu'il était rachidique
creuses il a des bonnes jours
comme ça à peu près et 25 kg
la police a dit qu'il n'était pas
vaccinée parce que c'est vrai aucun
vaccin c'est un peu délicat d'entrer
dans le secret
professionnels qu'il a dû suspendre pour
raison médicale voilà alors le médecin
vous menace d'appeler la police donc
vous décidez quand même de rentrer à la
maison c'est ça pourquoi il vous menace
d'appeler la police que franchement je
vous dis la vérité c'est là que
tu t'es spectateur et je pensais on
comprend pas c'est-à-dire vous allez à
l'hôpital parce que votre fils fait un
malaise suite à une allergie et là il y
a un médecin qui vous rattrape parce que
généralement aux urgences on est content
quand vous portez parce qu'on se dit il
y a tellement de monde que quand les
personnes partent on se dit bon bah ça
va mieux au moins on en a évité un peu
donc quand le médecin vous suit vous
attrape vous dit Foresti et que il y a
eu un truc c'était quoi c'était
l'apparence peut-être de votre fils qui
lui a fait peur qui s'est dit cet enfant
il est en mauvaise santé
oui peut-être des choses aussi purement
administratives quand j'étais tellement
pressurisée on a passé la nuit aux
urgences bon fils était malade tellement
de pressurisation on m'a demandé de
signer une feuille de décharge à la
sortie et j'ai juste c'est normal c'est
normal
le médecin j'ai jamais vu un médecin on
va parler avec avec Maître Ludo mais
j'ai jamais vu un médecin courir après
un patient qui ne connaît pas ce qui me
connaissait pas c'est juste peut-être
que l'apparence physique de votre fils
était la fortement inquiété
c'est curieux
de d'avoir des idées reçues sur la
morphologie d'une personne qu'on se la
maison estimait qu'il était affamé
donc c'est ça
vous rattrape il faut être clair madame
les deux versions divergent mais le
médecin vous rattrape parce qu'il pense
que votre est en danger il pense que
l'enfant il voit un enfant qui parle
très peu qui est selon les malnutrits
qui pèsent un poids de moitié inférieure
au point normal et le médecin est
inquiet et la machine va se mettre en
marche ils vont alerter les services
sociaux le médecin quand il vous
rattrape il pense que la vie de l'enfant
peut être enceinte vous avez dit qu'il
parle très peu c'est ça c'est ce que dit
les services sociaux
il est au contraire très connu pour
avoir un très bon niveau d'élocution
être très à l'aise en dialogue mais
comment vous expliquer que tous vos
propos que j'entends totalement sont à
l'inverse de tout ce que disent les
médecins les services sociaux puis le
juge etc la différence est incroyable
c'est très curieux mais les personnes
qui nous connaissent dans notre vie de
tous les jours
confirme les propos que vous avez des
témoignages de ces personnes là
c'est vrai que là on se dit bon
le médecin il a vu un danger pour votre
fils et là je vous dis 25 kilos à 14 ans
normalement c'est 5 1 kg 50 kg pour un
enfant de 14 ans forcément la moitié du
poids ça doit ça doit choquer donc le
médecin vous menace d'appeler la police
vous ne voulez pas vous rendre au
commissariat à cause de l'état de santé
de votre fils puisque la police quoi
vient chez vous
le lendemain matin
il m'appelle
mon fils était donc en convalescence
avait besoin de repos
je le dis on a rien voulu entendre
m'a dit c'est quoi cette mère qui ne
sait pas retirait son enfant du livre
donc on m'a sommé de nous rendre au
commissariat ok j'ai eu mon cœur de
maman déchiré parce que mon fils avait
visiblement très très besoin de repos
plus comme il était tombé dans les
pommes c'était un peu dangereux même de
d'aller jusque là-bas il est tombé
une grosse énergie il a l'air juste à
cause de quoi
de pastilles pour la gorge certainement
il avait mal à la gorge
il faisait très chaud c'était au début
juillet j'avais mis le ventilateur à
fond mais ça vient de se passer non je
comprends pas
ça vient de se passer
[Musique]
oui bah oui quelques jours plus tard en
fait vous passez au tribunal et la
décision de la juge est claire elle
demande 9 mois de placement pour votre
fils
Emmanuel
comment une juge peut demander neuf mois
de placement pour le fils de de
Stéphanie s'il n'était pas en danger
vous savez les juges des enfants
ils appliquent le principe de précaution
ils ont des des signaux qui sont des
Chinois inquiétants ils ont des rapports
qui sont faits par les services sociaux
et ils ont effectivement l'exposé qui
est fait par le médecin
urgentiste de l'hôpital en question
qu'est-ce qu'on fait on place on met
l'enfant à l'abri
et on peut on regarde
on fait les expertises
on analyse la situation et ensuite après
on se revoit et on prend la décision de
maintenir ou pas le placement c'est ce
qui s'est passé alors justement
qui était confirmé est-ce que le 26
avril dernier vous repasser à nouveau
dans le tribunal qui redemande 18 mois
de placement supplémentaire
il y avait 9 mois il en rajoute
absolument mais toute la question
aujourd'hui c'est si vous voulez c'est
ce décalage qu'il y a comme vous dites
très justement c'est ce décalage qu'il y
a entre
le discours de la maman vous voyez c'est
pas c'est pas une hystérique c'est pas
une saute le discours de cet enfant qui
manifestement
s'exprime à une personnalité très
particulière mais là sa personnalité et
puis le discours des services sociaux on
a le sentiment qu'on a à faire à un
dossier qui est qualifié de maltraitance
mais c'est la PAL c'est pas la
maltraitance habituelle habituellement
c'est 9 fois sur 10 c'est milieu social
défavorisés c'est une misère morale
c'est une misère financière matérielle
et c'est des enfants qui sont certes
dénutri battus malheureux alors là on
trouve une maman
là on trouve une maman qui a un bagage
intellectuel qui est quand même
relativement élevé qui vient d'un milieu
social aisé et qui vit seul avec son
enfant et qui a un discours qui est
diamétralement opposé à celui des
services sociaux on a le sentiment mais
il y a de lecture soit effectivement il
sait pas casser quelque chose d'anormal
et il y a des corrections à faire soit
on ne comprend pas le mode éducatif de
cette maman et on veut par la force
quelque part la reformater et la mettre
dans les rats qui sont les rails
j'allais dire du discours officiel de
l'éducation officielle alors c'est il y
a deux lectures dans ce dossier j'avoue
que pour la première fois j'ai quand
même été
un peu déstabilisé surtout quand j'ai vu
l'article qui a été fait dernière
excellente par votre confrère du Figaro
ou journaliste est allé enquêter chez
les bouquinistes de Rennes qui disent
mais on le connaît bien il est très
particulier il a il a beaucoup de
discours il discute il part il achète
des bouquins etc c'est-à-dire qu'il a
une il a un discours des quasiment d'un
adulte et on le connaît on le connaît
parce que d'abord il est dehors il est
pas reclu parce qu'il a un certain
bagage intellectuel mais qu'est-ce qui
se passe madame pardonnez-moi mais moi
j'ai le sentiment que c'est moi qui
parle là j'ai le sentiment que c'est il
apprend ce qu'il a envie d'apprendre il
apprend pas ce qu'il a pas envie
d'apprendre
c'est un peu le patron quoi la maison et
le poids et le poids c'est le poids là
le poids moi j'ai pas Lucas j'ai pas lu
25 j'ai eu dans le dossier 33 d'accord
1m4733 bon est-ce que c'est un enfant
qui effectivement est fluait qui va
faire ça qui va faire son soin d'Adolphe
sa croissance plus que 14 ans 1m47 c'est
c'est c'est petit oui c'est dommage une
photo dans la loge je pourrais vous
montrer son son visage vous verrez que
quand vous l'avez vu ils a choqué
l'enfant physiquement c'est à dire vous
avez senti qui souffrait pas du tout non
non je crois que il y a
là où moi je suis pas d'accord c'est sur
le c'est le but recherché il est louable
bon c'est sur la méthode séparer la mère
de l'enfant alors qu'on a pas à faire à
de la maltraitance au sens au physique
où on l'entend était à mon avis une
mauvaise chose moi j'avais dit au juge
des enfants écoutez faites un placement
à domicile dire que l'enfant reste à la
maison mais mais il aura des éducateurs
qui viendront tous les jours et qui
viendront vérifier qu'il va à l'école
qui les vacciné qu'il est suivi bref qui
va retrouver sa vie d'adolescents et une
adolescent comme tous les gamins sont
nages ça c'était une mesure qui était
sage et intelligente on a décidé
autrement de les séparer est-ce que
c'est une bonne chose je ne crois pas
est-ce que l'enfant il vaut mieux
maintenant
j'en suis pas sûr on est-ce qu'il y a
des problèmes d'accès j'en suis pas sûr
là il est en foyer c'est ça ça se passe
bien pour lui non ça se passe très mal
il dit que votre fils se plante violence
physique morale verbale mais vous ne le
sentez pas libre dans ses paroles c'est
ce que vous dites c'est à dire
même moi j'ai un peu du mal à en parler
en fait et vous dit quoi dans son foyer
il est triste
disons un univers très bienveillant Dans
la communication le dialogue la liberté
et tout ça volait en éclat il est
heureux avec vous
puis je vous demandais madame si vous
faites partie d'une secte c'est un
mouvement religieux vous n'êtes pas
obligé parce que c'est très intime vous
pouvez me poser la question
et je vous réponds par la négative
d'accord est-ce que c'est ce que
beaucoup de gens ont dit vous faites
partie d'une secte etc j'ai une question
à poser il s'appelle comment votre fils
il s'appelle comment
l'émission
moi moi je pensais une chose Emmanuel
Ludo c'est je pense que tous les
téléspectateurs se disent la même chose
que moi votre fils
il est plus malheureux en foyer que chez
vous
vous confirmez
je confirme pas j'ai affirme pas
ça c'est non mais c'est vrai c'est faut
être prudent dans ses propos là c'est
aux éducateurs de répondre c'est au
psychologue de répondre il dit qu'il est
il est violenté dans son foyer est-ce
qu'il va mieux et ce qui va moins bien
ce qui va grossir ce qu'il a pris du
poids
mais surtout est-ce qu'il était heureux
d'être avec vous il le dit ah oui oui
chaque médecin
c'est ce qui est capable de le
verbaliser vous n'avez qu'un droit de
visite très limité madame deux fois par
mois une heure trente le juge ne veut
pas que vous voyez très souvent
on verra la fin si vous voulez ce qui
est ce qui est inquiété dans ce type de
stratégie de protection de l'enfance
c'est que il a 14 ans on va renouveler
tous les ans tous les 18 mois et on va
aller gentiment jusqu'à ses 18 ans faut
pas se faire d'illusions et à 18 ans on
va lui dire écoute mon gamin tu as 18
ans bah tu te sauves tu t'en vas un peu
plus rien pour toi donc ça va redevenir
un électron libre
sans rien
sans repère et il va falloir qu'il
retrouve une visière il moi ça me paraît
pas très constructif juste vous avez dit
que vous aviez peur de représailles de
qui pourquoi en fait j'ai pas compris ça
mon fils est dans une situation très
très difficile actuellement et
et
ceux qui nous font vivre une situation
difficile ne veulent pas que ça sache
voilà
parce que la clé de l'histoire elle est
là alors c'est simplement que c'est
l'avion collectivité
avec d'autres garçons qui sont placés
pour d'autres motifs et que la vie en
collectivité dans ce dans ces endroits
là c'est un petit peu la jungle parfois
il faut se battre il faut se j'allais
dire c'est la vie c'est la vie qu'il
apprend mais ce qu'il faut faire madame
pardonnez-moi je le dis publiquement il
faut que vous collaboriez avec les
services sociaux tant que vous n'aurez
pas décidé de collaborer avec eux la
situation sera gelée il faut écouter
maître Ludo
parce que j'ai l'impression que le
l'enfant il souffre aussi là-bas donc à
un moment voilà leur pathologique des
autres il paraît voilà parfaitement il
est très spontané
vous avez vous allez juger très à l'aise
en dialogue il a pas d'inhibition
sociale
il a des sujets de discussion et des
sujets et des centres d'intérêts qui ne
sont pas forcément sur son âge donc ça
doit être très compliqué pour lui en
foyer
avec des gosses qui sont des
par ailleurs de faire des tournois de
cartes avec d'autres enfants avoir
d'autres enfants depuis qu'il est petit
et vous madame vous avez pas eu de suivi
psychologique vous personnellement
durant cette année est-ce que vous il y
a eu vous avez su vous avez vu des
psychologues qui ont fait une analyse à
part le fait de que pour une mère
évidemment ça fait c'est très douloureux
de savoir son enfant qui souffre qui est
violenté
finalement la situation est très
douloureuse